Does too much smoothie mix stuff decrease the effects of bedbed is all so
That's too if you're putting a bunch of different things in your smoothie with bedbed is all
I think that's the question. There's a decrease the effects of bedbed is all
No, I mean no
You should still be able to absorb bedbed is all and it's gonna be it's completely different than the other stuff
So no, no, it shouldn't decrease the effects of bedbed is all no
Does I could be eight if took bedbed is all with your meal you got a whole bunch of food in your god
Is that gonna decrease the effects? You don't need to take bedbed is all an empty stomach that a factor
It's been shown that that bedbed is all is more better absorbed if you take it with fat
So if you take it with a meal, you got some fat in that meal
It's gonna be better absorbed so no I wouldn't I wouldn't say that's decreasing the effects at all no